take politics out of this i personally  felt very embarrassed and the reason i  felt embarrassed  was it made scotland look small you know  we're not a country in the end that goes  for these  gestures you know we're not a country  that in the end wants to dwell on  grievances or gripes on scoring a cheap  point against against england or against  britain and i think that was a very bad  mistake just as by the way last week  when the scottish  office in the uk government put out that  statement that scotland will be 1400  better or better off without  independence and they gave the example  of fish and chips that you could buy or  holidays and tory molinas i thought that  was patronizing so people can make  mistakes and i think mr simon ought to  recognize that that made scotland  because these pictures were shown all  over the world and i would never have  done that and i think it made scotland  seem small when i actually think  scotland should be big